good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of baber district council
cabinet
i'm councillor john ward leader of baby
district council and i'll be chairing
this meeting
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down
or if you're exempt from doing so and
that you use the hand sanitizer and
whites provided please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please not interrupt other speakers or
hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending this meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
go members make sure they are logged in
and ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'll now move to the agenda so item one
apologies for absence
received chair
thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare anyone
nope thank you
three paper bca2134 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on 6th of
december 2021
so we have the minutes there on pages 5
to 14
of your agenda pack
does anyone have any questions on any of
the contents of those minutes
counselorathy
yeah
it's um page 12
75.2
um and three lines up from the bottom
it's just a typo
rather than initially
that should read initial
the initial proposal
not the initially proposal thank you
councilworthy yep we'll get that
corrected any other questions anyone on
the minutes
in which case may i have a proposal
please
council busby
and a seconder
councillor osborne
right um i'll now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair
excuse me members that vote is now in
progress
councillor crawl
thank you
councillor osborne are you logged in yet
thank you
thank you mr chair that's
eight votes four and one against that's
good
okay then moving on
item four
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the castle's petition
scheme
received
item 5 questions by councillors
non-received
and item 6 matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
i'll now invite the chair of the
overview and scrutiny committee council
mclaren to present the recommendations
from the overview and scrutiny committee
council mclaren thank you mr german
chair and cabinet members
on the 7th of february 2022 the legally
required annual scrutiny of the draft
general fund budget and four-year
outlook
and the draft housing revenue account
and four year outlook was undertaken by
the weber
overview on the scrutiny committee
the committee
was reassured by the presentations and
information
provided by the cabinet member for
finance
the assistant director of corporate
resources and the assistant director
housing that all due diligence had been
applied to the statutory financial
processes required
in relation to the two items
bos stroke 21
0-1 draft general budget 22 23 and
four-year outlook our recommendations
are as follows
that the overview and scrutiny committee
notes the general fund 22
20
23 and four-year outlook
and the second recommendation on that is
that the overview and scrutiny committee
receives a report from cabinet on the
outcomes of the performance framework on
a six-month basis
the second item was bos stroke 21 stroke
zero two draft housing revenue account
and four year outlook
our recommendations are
that the overview and scrutiny committee
notes the draft housing revenue account
2022-23 and the four-year outlook
and the second recommendation is that
the overview and scrutiny recommends
that the information
about the use of subcontractors
be included in the quarterly performance
monitoring report
cabinet members can see in the attached
papers the wide-ranging press questions
raised by the committee during the
meeting
thank you chair
thank you council mclaren yes there were
quite a few questions and it's
interesting reading through those um
do members have any questions for
council mclaren
councilman crawl
thank you chair thank you
good afternoon mary um
question on the what recommendation in
1.2
um the overview and scrutiny committee
was asking for report from cabinet
on the outcomes of the performance
framework on a six-month basis now we
currently
present a quarterly performance report
and that comes through
the
uh the investment that i i represent so
is it a suggestion that
two of the quarters be put together so
you would have quarters one and two and
quarters three and four
put together and then presented through
a cabinet then on to overview and
scrutiny
is that is that the suggestion
um
that sounds so you know reasonable to me
um
we did say six months we were talking i
mean we're talking about a new
development here aren't we a developing
framework
well that that's my point there's not
been no discussion made um um through
officers um or myself on how this could
be handled and i'd like some guidance
and i'd like cabinet obviously to have
some discussion on what could be done as
it is we present a quarterly report on
the outcomes um which i have
we do four of those a year
if we're going to increase the workload
for officers and i'm sure it can be put
together
basically had one and two and three and
four
the question is really will that give
you give you any more information and
isn't that a process that's just
duplicating the report to council
through the quarterly reports so i'm
just not sure where the value is being
added here
i've got to say that we were under the
impression that there was a new group of
people coming together for this process
so we're probably not talking about what
was already in existence does that
clarify yeah i think so fundamentally
this is actually a piece of work that
could be said to be in progress because
each of the directorates is working on
how we will feed into the outcomes
framework and what we will produce
so this is probably a little premature
for us to be able to say whether this is
this recommendation is possible
so i'd like some further consideration
of that before we've either vote on it
or before i personally feel i could vote
for it
yeah thank you councilman cry and
understand where you're coming from um
obviously at this point we're just
noting the um the recommendations from
the overview and scrutiny committee but
um we will be able to take this forward
and look at it in more detail in terms
of the practical implementation of it at
a later date and then you'll be able to
look at that with
with your assistant can i just say chair
that i'm happy to discuss it outside of
this meeting with councillor mccrory
that'd be great thank you casa mclaren
any other questions for council mclaren
council arthi well i i had a very very
similar question um and i'm still not
quite clear what the answer is
um overview and scrutiny can
um consider whatever they want whenever
they want and i got the impression from
this that you were saying that around
about november time you would like
to discuss the quarter one and quarter
two
out term performance that's what i read
it to me
but it isn't very clear in your
recommendation as council and mccraw
picked out
um but there's there's i don't see any
reason why you shouldn't do that but i
just wasn't quite clear exactly what it
meant either but i think it means that
when the
quarter two figures are out you would
like to consider the quarter one and
quarter two figures so the first six
months um which would take you i'm just
looking around to see if anybody's gonna
nod but i think it would be around about
november end of november beginning of
december time wouldn't it before those
figures are available
can i can i just
respond to cancer cancerously i think
there's some difficulty here in what the
overview and scrutiny committee were
related referring to
we were not referring to anything that
is in place at the moment
and it was about some of the
budget
includes new expenditure on a newly
formed team looking at performance and
it was the newly formed team
performance that we were going to we
were requesting
for a review
can i ask the monitoring officer
actually because um we agreed the
recommendation
can i ask her just to clarify for us
thank you
thank you jay yes i did attend um the
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
where this was discussed and i think the
essence of the recommendation was less
about reporting on the performance
outcomes that are considered by the
cabinet but actually reporting on the
effectiveness of the new uh monitoring
framework so it's about having a review
of looking at whether the uh new um
performance um or the outcome led
performance framework and the team
that's been put in place to support that
whether that's delivering on its
objectives um and less concerned with
kind of reporting on the uh the
performance indicators that are included
in in those quarterly reports to cabinet
thank you
thank you emily councillor mccraw do you
want to just to make an observation that
since the um tier 4 outcomes in the
outcomes framework are currently only
now under development from each of the
directorates
and since
bringing those
establishing what the framework is and
then providing measurement
of that
it's going to be at least three months
to get this set up another six months to
collect the figures probably another
three months to collate them and present
them so effectively i think we may be a
little premature here i would say you
could be talking a year from now before
it would be possible to uh to provide
the ons and i'm also not certain that it
would be cabinet producing
the said report which is why i think
some further discussion is required
thank you council mccraw
any other questions from anyone
in which case i think it comes from
mclaren for your report
and we'll now move on to item seven the
forthcoming decisions list you've all
had a link to the latest version of that
does anyone have any comments or
questions around the forthcoming
decisions list we've got
um uh
agenda items therefore uh
council cabinet uh going through
for the next couple of months or so now
there's quite a full schedule in there
for march
and also we've got april and may
does anyone have any questions
no
in which case
we will move on then and i'll move on to
item eight which is paper bca2135
the general fund budget for 2022-23 and
four-year outlook and i'll now invite
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce the report councillor barrett
uh good afternoon everyone uh yep so we
have the general fund budget for 22 23
in the four-year outlook
um this has
been produced
with
a slightly different set of criteria
this year
in the past we've obviously the budget's
been produced and um it's been very
cautious
uh which has resulted in um
a certain amount of inaccuracy when we
get our out turn so our position looks
quite negative to start with or very
small and then at the end the out turn
we've had quite big variances so um the
team have looked at this and
drilled down on the numbers
substantially to make sure that we get a
more accurate picture of our expenditure
it's always difficult on the income side
because we rely on the government
and our settlement which comes out
around about the 16th of december
to be able to put the income side in so
we've held back again later this year
to get a more accurate view of the
income which actually was favorable this
year we had a better position than we
had anticipated in terms of we thought
we'd have a reduction in new homes bonus
but in fact it was kept relatively the
same
so this has resulted in us having a
quite a good settlement this year
bring forward the
element of
extra money we had for the covert
situation which we haven't totally spent
so that's been brought forward as a
positive balance with 705 000 a an
element of that will be spent um dean
comey
which has left us in a situation where
we
were
having um a surplus of around 400 000
without any increase in our council tax
but um
we can with the government allowed us to
increase that council tax to five pounds
we decided that it would be sensible to
have a certain amount of increase in our
overall budget position because we have
got obviously
inflationary costs coming forward which
seem to be higher
so we are recommending
a 2
increase which is a midpoint that gives
our band d
properties an increase of 3 pounds 50
per annum
which is 29 pence per month
so it's not a great deal
per month
no per month
it's only 350 a year
just clarifying that with the leader
there if anyone couldn't hear that
so we we're we're below inflation with
our increase
um which i think is a sensible position
to be in which gives us an annual um out
turn surplus of 527
000 which is quite nice for our 22-23
year
but the other thing we need to take into
account because obviously our
medium-term financial position still
shows us in year 25-26 with a 2.3
million pound deficit now
that is um
something we should be concerned about
and obviously we were looking to make
sure that that deficit does not
materialize um it's a slightly one-sided
case because what we've what happens
with the budget it tends to be that all
the costs are known and we can put the
costs and increase costs in one thing we
don't know is the amount of income and
extra income that we receive in those
periods
that should balance out and obviously we
will be in a position where going
forward we will have a balanced budget
but that is why it is prudent at this
stage to
have a 2 increase even though without
that increase we were still showing a
surplus
so i have
um the task now of recommending uh item
three
on the agenda uh which is 3.1 and 3.2 uh
if i could have a proposal please well
i'm proposing sorry i need a second uh
thank you councillor barrett uh uh
secondary councillor busby were you
seconding
yeah happy second yep
okay uh so thank you councillor barrett
um
i'll open it up to questions um members
of the cabinet uh
councilman vici
thank you mr chairman um councillor
barrett on page 29 item 4
10
the last point
it's talking historically
because it states reduced climate change
and biodiversity impact
where financially viable well if you're
assessing the financial viability it
should be current
i think
yeah i'd take that point are you
suggesting we have reducing
reduce or reducing
i think that probably reads better
doesn't it
it's not finite then
yeah and then on page 37
uh
items 5.6 and 5.7 are discussing the new
home bonus
which is decreasing
i have to ask what's the point of
building all the new homes if we're not
going to get a new homes bonus
i totally agree and it's one of the
areas which i always feel is we're
setting budgets when we're so dependent
on that now and we don't know what we're
going to receive
this is why i i mentioned it in the
medium-term financial strategy because
if if we could rely on our new homes
bonus at the current level then our
position on the um
out turn would not be 2.3 million
deficit we'd actually probably be in a a
positive situation
yeah and thank you councilmembers yeah
i'm fortunate with the new homespun
assassin with um
all of the the the government funding it
everything is done on a uh seems to be
at the moment on a year-on-year basis
and we just can't
um project further than that so
we know what we're going to get for the
forthcoming year um and we'll have to
wait until next
november december time to find out what
they're going to do for subsequent years
but
um it's for the past few years it's been
one year at a time any other questions
councillor davis
yeah i'm just um curious as to uh
because about says we didn't really need
to increase the council tax where they
decided to do that but given the current
circumstances with
income tax
national insurance rather national
insurance contributions being raised the
energy prices rocketing food prices
rocketing
wouldn't it have been better to actually
have introduced the car parking charges
and not increased
the
council attack charges to the majority
of our residents who are struggling
financially as it is
well um
clearly
we could have introduced parking charges
which um if you're worrying about the
cost to our residents um then clearly
29 p per month or one pound per hour
i think the maths are there i mean if if
i was
a resident
living in and around sudbury hadley
and i went to the town once a week and
was introduced to having to pay one
pound for a parking fee or two pounds or
whatever or i'm faced with the choice of
29 p per month
i think i know which i'd rather have
and i think also the other thing that we
need to take into account is um
the impact of uh
no council tax rise is not just for the
the current year it has a knock-on
effect in subsequent years
and once you've missed that point
you you can never get that back
but the other point of course which is
one of the reasons we also consider that
the parking charges which as council
davis has brought up
um you know we are here also conscious
of the fact that our high streets are
under a considerable under pressure and
we do want to maintain a competitive
advantage with other people and even the
fact that we have not put car parking
charges in or up we're still losing
retailers on the high street
so what would the effect have been and
what signal and message would be sent
out have we put car parking charges on
um to the high street when we're already
losing them at quite a rate anyway
thank you council barrett council davis
did you have a another question yeah
well
that question hasn't really been
answered he's defended by people in
sudbury so he can win a few extra votes
get the benefit but the whole district
is losing out on this and plus there's
also the other the green aspect in terms
of the footpaths and the motoring as has
been pointed out elsewhere you know
quite frankly it's the whole of baby and
and while i agree that um i'm not saying
keep it at zero a smaller percentage
rise would have been more in order for
the benefit of the whole of baby
district
council baron
well again council davis is um looking
at this with rather rose contained
respectables i mean if you look at the
amount of income that's generated by the
residents of sudbury great corner
pinewood um compared with the uh the
whole of the area and that does cover
the majority i mean if you're looking at
the 90
78 000 residents that are in in baby
about probably within five miles of
suburban hadley the majority of that
seventy or thousand is within that area
they use those car parks so to say that
it's it doesn't benefit i think is
probably not the case because those
people do use those car parks the fact
he lives on the edge of the district
which is unfortunate for him because he
doesn't enjoy the benefits of working
and living in sudbury
yeah oh well i question councillors
barrett's figures for a start because i
don't believe the sudbury and had any
make up the most um they spent and also
because i work in hadley i do go there
and i'm quite happy with the one hour
free parking that that's more than
enough time um or you know find
somewhere else to go to as well because
people go to these towns for the offer
for what's on offer and if the offer is
not good enough then people won't go so
i don't think there's any basis in fact
for what he's saying there's no evidence
as we've seen by the independent report
that free parking helps high street
businesses
none
so i disagree and as for living in
shortly i couldn't be prouder an
absolutely fantastic place to live
and we benefit so much and of course we
have car park at pin mill which
residents pay for and they pay for it
and visitors pay for it because it's an
attraction worth going to so people will
pay if it's worth their while
yeah uh thank you councillor um
i i don't think we really want to reopen
the the car parking debate and we we
know the um the arguments on both sides
of that and uh but yes and i'm pleased
that you're
standing up for shortly and and also
chairman and pin mill and they are
lovely places um the oral s3 there is is
one of the uh
the jewels in babies crown i think
um
the the other just before i go on to
council hulk who who's got a question um
with regard to the the council tax
increase
the two percent that we're proposing is
not the full five pounds per annum um so
we are um mindful of the the impact on
on our residents but of course that the
baby element of council tax is only a
tiny percentage of what residents pay
it's uh less than about 10 i believe uh
that the bulk of um uh council tax and
indeed the bulk of the increases that
people are unfortunately going to have
to
um pay for the forthcoming year uh are
due to county council and police
precepts so um we're a small small very
small part of that council halt
yeah i'd just like to say that um the
two percent is something i'm very happy
with um
i think it's um
a very wise decision to protect our base
line
for the future
just picking up one thing the high
streets
i'd like to
make a comment that both hadley and
sudbury have been very resilient through
covid and have done exceptionally well
with the independent shops we have there
and our
vacancy rates are still very low
compared to the national average so i i
think it's a little bit harsh to
knock them down like that i think
they've done very very well and are
quite resilient and i'd like to applaud
the way they have coped with themselves
through the pandemic
hey castle councilman crawl
i'd just like to pick up on a point of
comparison being made by councillor
barrett there
um comparing one figure with another are
we
um we're still really in questions uh um
if this is okay
can we move on to that let's just just
focus on questions first
any other questions
council busby
thank you yes i just like to say that uh
catherine it's your last presentation to
the cabinet so
thank you do you want me do you want me
to reel off all 27 questions in a run or
would you like to take them one at a
time i actually have a question on the
capital expenditure on page 53
which is on the economic development and
regeneration line bellevue refurbishment
2 million pounds
uh the question is
is that a set two million
what happens if we
as we seem to think we've done seller
site for let's say
a million pounds is that million pounds
added into that 2 million so that we
then spend 3 million on it or does it
knock
our
borrowing requirement down by a million
pounds
so that's one question
and the second question is really
is that dependent upon the project that
we actually finally settle on
because it was six million for a hotel
now it's two million possibly for a
retirement home
if it's not a retirement home does the 2
million pounds change it again
thank you
thank you
councillor barrett would you like to
respond yeah um i don't if you remember
uh councilman busby that was put in the
request of the economic development team
be you know was i think might be your
team assets
um i think it was put in by assets
because
it was to enable
the project to be able to be completed
with the entrance to bellevue park which
was considered some which
would not be covered by the sale of the
land to uh churchill so that was why it
was put in and it's a sort of
provisional figure to be able to cover
the park entrance plus that i'm pretty
certain that's correct isn't it
catherine
so it didn't doesn't answer the question
as to whether the
the proceeds
from the sale will reduce that as a
borrowing requirement for us or whether
we're planning on borrowing the two
million pounds
um i i think i think i'm pretty certain
the reason it's put in is because
it was a figure that was deemed to be
roughly in line with what we're likely
to spend plus the
income from the sale of the land
so um i think that which would
effectively i think it's a i'm not sure
if that's in the public domain the sale
price but it was a combined figure that
would have given
uh the development cost that's why the
the the two million was put in as a
provisional figure
so it
i don't think it will go down
fiona would you like to say anything
um yeah obviously we we haven't got the
final costings yet for the bellevue
entrance um
i think my understanding about the
current two million is that it will it's
actually borrowing and of course the
capital receipt um
which hopefully we'll get from the sale
of the other land um will go into um
into the capital programme hopefully at
some point but that the two million is
is for is borrowing that's allocated for
use of bellevue
thank you fiona
does that answer your question council
buzzfeed i'll save you the 26 questions
for for council
okay thank you
are there any other questions from
anyone councilman malvisi um councillor
barrett page 53
[Music]
and i've lost it myself hang on a minute
um you've got yeah planned maintenance
enhancement of car parks is that 7 000
pounds
for next year
and that's to cover how many car parks
um
i don't think that's changed actually
that's the thing that was being in there
all along
i only reduced i only raise it because
in my own ward
we've refurbished the old school car
park at a much greater cost
um there isn't that
the signage alone
the the planned maintenance hasn't
changed
that's that's the figure 7 000. but if
you look further along it goes to 45
000. so there's obviously potential but
also in the capital programme this year
in this financial year there is the
replacement of the parking meters which
is in this capital spend program
yeah
but this 7000 is for next year well
there is i mean there isn't really much
in terms of
and the replacement of refuse freighters
at 2000
yeah that attire two million two million
is it two million okay sorry i sit
corrected
thank you but that's under discussion as
well
i mean it's been put in the budget but
it might be that there might be
different ways of funding those and
that's being investigated at the moment
okay rather than us spending all the
money on capital it could be that we go
and look at leasing but that's one of
the options that's been considered
at this stage so it hasn't been
finalized yet but it's prudent to put
the capital amount which we've in the in
the previous uh method of funding those
has been always been that we've bought
them so that's what's been in the
program now
so you're thinking of moving it to a
revenue expenditure rather than a
capital expenditure
well it effectively it would be the same
because obviously when it goes in once
once the money's been spent then there's
an element of the
cost goes into every budget as uh as uh
as uh the borrowing for those
thank you
uh counselor arthi
yeah it's no it's not working is it
working yeah um so it's it's kind of
linked to some of the previous questions
actually so i think it probably is a
question rather than debate
um and it's concerning the answers i
suppose that councilor barrett has given
on the question from
councillor davis where councillor davis
responded and said of course we do have
a car park on the peninsula and weber
charges for that all the time
i think
one of the interesting things about that
is and i can understand why councillor
davis is concerned and that is because
the the potential changes to the car
park at pin mill were part of
um the the postponed um
expenditure
announced by councillor dawson who i
think is here today is she
no
is she oh she's there
and um
and of course that was about 250 000
pounds i think that we would have
budgeted for
um to look at the expansion of the pin
mill car park but i do understand i may
be wrong here
that some of the um
some of the costs
for projects that we had been told would
be postponed
and are not actually going to be
postponed at all um councillor barrett
has already mentioned the parking
machines and i understand the
installation of new parking machines is
underway
and
that that part of the project will
probably be completed in this year
um so pre april 2022
but i also understand um that some of
the other improvement works to the car
parks
are budgeted for
for next year
um and that relates to both sudbury and
hadley
and these were
issues that i think council davis was
concerned about and so were several
several other members
to do with improved signage
promotion
surfacing
and
the
white lining of
decent-sized bays and i understand that
that is in the um budget for next year
so i don't know if councillor barrett
can just confirm that
um i don't think basically we don't see
much point in doing it when we've got a
car parking review coming forward
which is
defining what our requirements are what
what how we look at our car parks that
review is coming forward and that will
be in
i think it's
later this year i think hopefully around
november time am i right
there's a strategic parking review so it
seems pointless to um
sort of preempt by having um within this
year's budget or the coming budget
um something which we might have
different changes for and we need to
obviously then look at the costs and i
think the following year there's more
money being put in which will probably
be identified
the likely changes coming forward so it
just seems to be doing it in the right
way so let's see what we're what our
requirements are when we've got the
requirements we would then look to see
what the costs are of implementing the
requirements if they go through as
recommended recommendations are adopted
so that's basically where we are with
that
right i think thanks for that council
rather oh others
first of all only because it doesn't
answer the question okay
counselor
um uh counselor then uh what
part of the question hasn't been
answered yet well whether there's 65 000
pounds in the budget for the
improvements to the access and
white lining arrangements at our car
parks in hadley and sudbury
castlebaron um as far as i'm aware
that's not in the capital programme that
has come forward this year and not been
requested
because obviously
the the the budget we're working on is
from the departments
and obviously if they haven't requested
that then we haven't put it in
and they haven't requested it because
it's in their budget
um well i think it is in their budget
but it's not because it's not in the in
the in the budget
they haven't requested any money to come
forward they put seven thousand pounds
in that budget we have not determined
the budget the department's
determined the budget and uh and we just
agreed with it
but they haven't requested it
counselor arthi we have seven thousand
pounds here uh in the capital program
for maintenance and enhancements of car
parks that's that's the figure that's in
in the budget yeah i presume that's for
weeding and and sweeping or something so
there's no other capital provision for
anything else well as i understood it um
there is
65 000 pounds
um that's already been budgeted
perhaps council dawson can help it's her
portfolio
sorry the 60 hours you may be talking
about is in this year's budget for the
new machines
well i've got that in at 70 000 yeah
obviously
we we can't anticipate what the
department the the the ao
the um
budget comes forward uh we we deal with
the requests that are put in so we can't
do any more than that
council dawson did you have any further
information for this yes i was just
going to say that i think that some
might be put in there um but
when the strategic parking view is done
i think we'll find the findings for that
we've had some of the formal things have
come back early last friday but maybe
some of things are in the budget and
some of the
things that
won't be actually happening next year so
i think you need to wait another couple
of weeks and we will be coming back to
you with a strategic which might give
you a better idea and understanding
um where was actually going to be spent
because last year we had a lot of things
in the budget for lighting and safety
did
actually that came out as a low priority
in this review so do we really need it
so um and those are things that we come
back to you for your decision in a few
weeks time to consider
i don't know if i'm straying into
debates here am i i think i think so yes
do you should i carry on well no um i'd
rather finish questions and then we can
move into debate a bit later if that's
all right
castle holt
yeah i just wonder what the uh
expenditure is for the leisure centers i
mean kingfish has just gone through what
a 2.4 million revamp and hadley's new
and i just wonder what the the figures
were for 100k and the 50k for the
ongoing costs i mean what are they for
i think an element of them is for their
electric um provision um
i think i might have to ask catherine on
that one because i think it's for to do
with the there's a
to do with funding of the green energy
source i think
thank you i think these allocations are
in the budget just for emergency repairs
as they're needed um something like a
leisure center whilst it has yet
recently or both of them have recently
been refurbished there are things that
happen in any particular year you know
things do break um and need repairing so
i think these are just annual
allocations to allow for any sort of
emergency repairs that need to happen at
the two leisure centres
and as i said
when i was thinking about there's a
amount
where we've got the green energy going
in and out there's a in and out figure
which makes it look a bit but we
actually benefit from that don't we at
the end of the day
that's the whole so these are just
contingency figures not actually for
expenditure
programs expenditure programs they're
just contingency that may roll over is
that right
that's certainly the indication that
um catherine has given us yeah um
certainly the the main uh capital
expenditure for the two leisure centres
has has already taken place in in the
current year and previous years um
that's both for the
refurbishment of kingfisher and the new
paul hadley plus all of the
work that's been done on solar panel
installation
any other questions council busby
yeah i think sticking on page 53 the
capital expenditure
we've got about a 16 million
carry forward and a six and a half
million new
for this year so giving us a total of
22.5 million pounds
um
targeted capital expenditure
we know that we never spend it all
but we've ever got to the year end and
has achieved all of our capital
requirements
how is the
cost of interest calculated for this
22.5 million pounds is it assumed that
we need to fund the whole 22.5 million
for the whole year or is it phased
across the year
um it's not the whole amount
and and that's again what also affects
the medium-term financial strategy
uh i think there's an assumption of
about 50 percent of that capital spend
is um
in that uh period going forward which
also incurs extra costs which makes our
position look worse than it actually is
but it would be nice that we're that
we're a babe of growth to get off and
moving uh
councillor busby that maybe we can spend
some of the capital that we've got
building up year on year
thank you councillor barrett i shall put
it in my diary
okay
if there are no further questions from
cabinet members
any other members
council mclaren do you have any
questions
thank you
right we will move now into debate and
um
just to to open
i'd like to say a couple of things
firstly
i do
appreciate the the presentation of the
the budget this year the pie charts that
we've got in it um are excellent and
they're very helpful and informative
pictorial representation
of the income and expenditure uh the
reserves the capital program very very
helpful
and um
while on the subject of the capital
programme
it is
and uh
there's already been mention of the the
carry forwards um some of those carry
forwards are long-term carry forwards
which uh are for long-term
um
regeneration and investment projects so
we're going to see those
continuing in the carry forward column
but uh we do have an ambitious capital
program
and i think we all of us want to see
some significant progress on on some of
these items um
uh in in the fourth coming year it would
be very helpful and i'm sure we will so
um
the capital program is there it uh
reflects our ambitions and um but for
the district
and uh i think it's uh
what we have here is is an excellent
set of priorities and potential projects
does anyone else wish to make any
comments uh firstly councillor barrett
and then councilman crawl
one of the things i failed to mention um
in the uh my opening uh remarks um we
also did look at the general fund um
reserve which we currently have about 12
of our budget
um
and that stands at 1.2 million
uh
what we have done is remove 200 000 of
that and put that into the general grant
fund
to help um well-being and
organizations be able to bid
to
get themselves back after covert bearing
in mind that fund there is our rainy day
fund and we've probably had the biggest
storms we've had in the last two years
and we've not touched that fund so in
concentration with catherine uh we we
felt well catherine felt as 151 officer
that it was perfectly uh prudent to be
able to reduce that to one million
pounds
um and release the money to help our
communities which i think is actually
very sensible so sorry i've got to
mention that i think that actually quite
a good point and shows where we're
putting money back and council davis's
team will be able to help distribute
that around shotley and the peninsula
because of clearly they need it more
than anyone else
uh thank you council bear yeah i i agree
that um diverting that money from the uh
the general fund reserve to the the
well-being reserve does make a lot of
sense um well-being is is
increasingly an important aspect of
what we provide um particularly in the
recovery from covert and i'm sure
council davis will i no doubt find good
uses for that 200 000 in his budget so
that's that's uh that's good news
councillor mccraw
thank you chair um i finally have to
take issue with an assertion made by
councillor barrett in answer to a
question
by councillor davis it makes a
comparison between
a 29 pound
109 pence a month charge
and a one pound charge for car parking
as though the two were comparable and
the assertion was that one pound is more
than 29 p so i know which i'd rather pay
well the two are not comparable they are
entirely different sorts of charges with
apples and pairs here the car parking
charges if instituted would only be paid
by the actual users
that one pound or two pound is not
comparable to any weekly or monthly or
any
other and regular payment it's a payment
for a service now that's a principle
that we use in our brand bin service
where people only pay if they've got a
garden with brown bin waste to go into
it
so in effect as the situation stands at
the moment
everybody in the district
everybody in the district who pays
council tax
um is already subsidizing
car parking for a minority an
arrangement that affects okay two large
communities i will admit there's
absolutely no true thing no question
about that but the point is
it is the majority supporting the
minority the implementation of these
charges has been agreed it's been
through extensive uh study
and the question has only been when will
it be implemented
and and fundamentally what i see
happening here is a political delaying
action
it's nothing to do with a strategic
parking review that's a separate process
as was covered very carefully in
scrutiny
uh the saving of instituting the car
parking would allow either us to reduce
the 29 per week as suggested by
councillor davis
sorry a month not a week
it might allow other service support or
it might improve our position on
reserves but with particular attention
to the ongoing uh budget deficits that
are forecast in the next three
financial years it gives us more
flexibility and frankly
it has a green agreed the implementation
of this so not to include it at all in
the budget
seems to me to be the sort of like
sliding it out of the way so that in the
hope that it will be forgotten i don't
think we should be doing that as a
matter of our financial responsibility
this is a decision we made and we should
be including it in the next budget
um thank you councilman crore i don't
wish to uh rerun the whole of the
parking debate now but um you're right
in in as much that um
a cabinet decision was made last year
um but it has been postponed
um
the fact that we don't yet have
um
an implementation date means we can't
include it in this year's budget now
what happens in next year's budget um
that's for next year for this time next
year but at the moment
as as we do not have an implementation
date
we won't be including any further
increase in parking revenue in in this
year's budget
we've already said that the
the council tax the proposed council tax
two percent uh is less than the maximum
that
we are allowed which is five pound per
annum um but uh the the issue is not
in terms of council taxes is not just a
matter of um this this year's numbers we
do need to ensure that we don't have uh
an
accumulative effect on subsequent years
and putting in a small castle tax rise
this year is going to protect us in
those years to come
council mccraw can i just follow up on
that because in effect um
we just signed off the minutes of the
december meeting where we agreed that
this would be delayed in implementation
we've agreed this so many times now i'm
beginning to lose count but effectively
it would seem to me that we're
suggesting that we haven't got a cabinet
capable of making a decision sticking to
it and implementing it and because we
aren't prepared to put it in our budget
we've got lots of things in this budget
that might not necessarily happen
because their provisions have been made
for them and we are arguing here that
the implementation cannot be included in
the budget
because it
might not happen well lots of things
might not happen so i don't see that
argument as holding up
okay thank you counselor um councillor
arthi
yeah i've got a couple of things to say
i mean earlier on you said that my
questions were starting to
verge into debate and then you started
debate without asking me
um firstly on that i'm not quite sure
that your answer was 100 right i don't
think this cabinet has made a formal
decision to postpone these capital works
i think that there was
a decision made
in
by the cabinet member responsible
in association with the
with the officer responsible so i don't
think it's actually this cabinet's
decision i think this cabinet's decision
goes back to february of last year but
that's actually irrelevant to what we're
talking about today
so what i was going to mention mention
earlier on um about what i understood
was going to be postponed and what
wasn't
as far as i understood it
the investigation into
[Music]
the enlargement
of the car parks in sudbury was part of
the review
the support for the highway schemes to
enhance parking facilities including the
reconfiguration of the access to great
eastern road car park in sudbury and the
station road car park and the possible
link to cornard road i understood that
they were all being delayed as a part of
the
the review which i have to say i don't
have any problem with that in fact i'm
not complaining about what i think is
happening at all because i think what's
happening is that we are going to
continue work on our car parks
irrespective of the charging review
which is what i wanted in the first
place
i didn't want to throw out the car park
improvements just because we were
delaying the implementation of the
review so as i understand it
there is some work that will carry on
in the coming year and i've mentioned
earlier on
what that is
whether i mean i understood that was out
of capital but you will notice
in our budget papers and my screen is
just gone
but we do actually have of course the
cost of car parking in there so earlier
on when councillor barrett was talking
about
um seven thousand pounds or something
towards
um
maintenance or something no i didn't say
anything
oh okay um you told me
no i didn't
i i didn't say anything but in the in
the in the capital program there's
allocation of seven thousand pounds i
didn't say what it's for so um if we
actually have a look at our revenue
budget
um we can see in there
um that there's a net cost of about 150
000 pounds which is 400 000 pounds um
cost of the provision of our car parks
less 150 000 pounds um
so it hasn't quite added up is it has
450
250 250 000 pounds
um in um charges but i can't find it on
my if you've got it up on your page yet
my computer unfortunately
are you referring to page 74 of the
budget book i'm referring to page
74 i am indeed
yeah
so that's um net on car parking
of um about 250 260 000 pounds
on a total cost of around about 400 000.
yeah
that is correct yes
if this is important i'll do a bit of
additional work before council if you
want me to clarify these points but i
think they're right
but those those numbers here
for the um
the costs employees premises and
supplies and services are for the um
day-to-day running of the car parks
including um business rates
yeah absolutely i just didn't want them
to get confused with what we were
talking about earlier on which was the
capital programme
correct
okay um i think we're all clear maybe
it's just a counselor i think it was
confusing
the only other comment i just wanted to
make on on some of the things you
mentioned counselorathy the um
reconfiguring of that station rogue
carthart junction around waitrose the
work on cornard road
crossings there that's all part of the
program of highways changes that we want
to implement um to support
uh the the buses um active travel
policies and that sort of thing so
they were part of our original leveling
up fund bid to finance those
um that's not part of any car parking
work
anyway um if we if anyone else has any
comments and i'd rather hope it's on
other aspects of the budget other than
car parks
council davis
yeah i can understand why you want to
avoid us talking about it but it is an
important aspect you know it does affect
the whole district as has been pointed
out and not just and not just a few in
uh you know to win a few votes in
sudbury and hadley um and also on top of
that you you mentioned and quite rightly
that baber's
um percentage of the council taxes is
among the smallest obviously the town
and parishes have um
you know a smaller amount or
percentage-wise they might be higher but
if you're looking at the whole thing um
yeah and we have to remember it's a
conservative-controlled soviet county
council a conservative
police and crime commissioner and this
is pretty much a conservative policy
here you know our residents were going
to be paying more than 1800 pound for
their council tax on top of as i
mentioned an increase in national
insurance a decrease in universal credit
increased
energy prices increased food costs and
just the general rise in living so i
still think you know we didn't need to
increase it by two percent
um and and therefore you know that's i
think it's wrong i think we're
penalizing the the hold of labor
you know when we could have increased
for example could have introduced the
car parking charges when this cabinet
agreed to do so for example
and and also i agree with cancer arthur
it's not particularly clear it's not a
great report
thank you thank you councilman davis um
uh
councillor malvisi
thank you mr chairman
um i fully endorse
councillor davis and councillor mcgraw
at the end of the day
parking charges is a choice
you choose to pay but you can also
choose to use it for just an hour and
you get the hour free
but
your council tax you go to jail if you
don't pay it
i don't think that quite applies to
parking thank you
okay um
we've got this budget in front of us
here um with the
uh recommendation for the two percent um
as i said the
parking charge decision has has been
postponed um it it has not been
cancelled and we will no doubt come back
and revisit it and and
discuss it again at
uh a later date um and should the
decision
or should we then come up with an
implementation date we will then be able
to include
the
additional income either in next year's
budget or it would
if that decision is made sooner it would
form part of an out turn on this budget
but at the moment we would not be
putting any provision in this budget
because
there has not
been no decision on a start date for
that so i think there's not a lot more
that we can say about it at this stage
so moving on councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman i'm not going to
be quite so contentious but you know to
increase the council tax by two percent
i feel is wise budget budget management
to ensure that we can continue to
provide services to our residents this
is what it's all about
there are some councils out there with
huge financial problems unfortunately
we're not one of them so we must
consider ourselves very lucky there
next year's budget of course will have
its challenges uh including the
implementation coming from government to
implement the collection of food waste
and to consider no charge for garden
waste
so by this increase we'll safeguard our
services
and protect our residents from even
bigger increase in next year so i will
be supporting the recommendation thank
you mr chairman
uh thank you council osmond i think you
make a couple of um
very relevant points there
we are fortunate in that we do have uh
sound finances here at baber um
admittedly we're not exposed to some of
the the very big um
uh
drains and
impacts on budgets that perhaps the the
county councils have
with their social services budgets but
nonetheless um even in comparison with
other districts i think we're doing very
well
and you make another
a very pertinent point about the um
resources and waste strategy that's
coming up although we have been promised
um full new burdens funding for any
additional costs that we might incur
with that um
that that at the moment is a promise
rather than a reality we don't yet know
what the increased costs are going to be
we don't yet know what um
support and that we will likely get from
government on that so we do need to be
mindful of that is coming down the line
and it is going to hit us in one form or
another in the next year or two
okay everyone
does anyone else have any further
comments they wish to make about the
budget
in which case
we've had
the uh the paper proposed and seconded
we've had a debate so i will now ask
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote on the general fund
budget
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
council macro
against thank you
councillor dawson have you been able to
log in yet would you like me to take
your vote verbally
thank you
okay
thank you
thank you members chair that's seven
votes four and three against
thank you thank you
right moving on then item nine paper
bca2136
the housing revenue account account 20
to 22 to 23 budget so i'll now invite
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce this report councillor barrett
please
thank you very much and yes this is the
housing revenue account for 2223
we have a fairly
healthy
hra
position
um
but we
have got a recommendation in 3.2
that we increase the council tax rents
by
cpi plus four subs plus one which gives
us four point one percent
and that means the uh
the um
rents
increase
uh
to um
three pounds 72 per week
um which and we're not imposing any uh
garage rents shelter housing stays the
same
and the utility charts should get the
same at the same levels this will give
us a surplus in the budget of
511
000
that will be transferred to street
forage funds within the hra budget it's
worth noting
that we have substantially increased the
building services
provision
that
we've had a problem with that in the
past and if you recall
in the quarter two out turn report we
were showing a 499
or half a million pound deficit in that
quarter
partly due to i think there's not enough
provision put in the budget but also
the cost of
implementing the
extra work that we've had as catching up
from the previous year
so effectively the in the within the
budget there is a
if you took the deficit and the extra
increase is almost a million pounds
going in there on top
which gives us the uh
hopefully sufficient so when we come to
the budget out turns will be more
accurate and that will reflect where we
actually are
so um i'd like to propose that we vote
on block on item three as rather than
each
listing
can i have a second opinion thank you
council also on your second thank you
okay cabinet members uh does anyone have
any questions
counselor arthur then council davis
yeah just a simple one really where do i
find um the
um
the assessment that we're doing on our
garage sites
we've had quite a lot of chat about what
we're going to do with these garage
sites
um there i think there are three options
um that have been spoken about where do
i find that in the budget the costs of
that work
mr barrett do you have an answer for
that i didn't know it was in the budget
as a separate item actually
i think surely that's down to the uh
that's down to um gavin's team whether
they have identified anything i think is
that a budget matter have you ever wants
to come in on this
it's not um it's not identified as a
separate item in the budget there is a
piece of work going on and continues and
i'm hoping that a report will be coming
forward very shortly but it's not
actually been not to my
knowledge has been identified as a
separate item
it's being covered by existing resources
thank you councillor
castle davis
yeah mine's quite simple really um
given the increase that we're proposing
in terms of the council tax
the
increase in national insurance
contributions the sky high food prices
energy costs where are we expecting our
tenants to get this money from this
extra 170 odd pound a year where where
they going to find it
i think you have to take in context that
um the average wheaty rental throughout
this area was 97 pounds a week
for a council house
i think that's considerably good value
than the open market value
and actually over the last five years
four of those years there was a
reduction in the rental
for the tenants
and that has now come back because
obviously there was a one percent
reduction that we had in each year
um
of of the number of tenants so we have 3
437 houses
1 682 or 49 of those are cons already on
housing benefit
so that would be covered by the increase
and of that 49
we cannot identify the people that are
on universal credit but also be entitled
to i'm pretty certain andrew if you
could help on that they were to get a
universal credit would they get an
increase in the
in the universe credit if their council
house went up
if the rent went up
yeah i mean their housing costs would be
considered within their universal
credits will be a change of
circumstances so um to answer councillor
dave's question yes i mean obviously
this is a problem but it's a problem for
everyone
um this is not just
everyone's having the higher up the
scale the bigger the amounts
so that i would i would suspect that the
people that are absolutely on the
the lower levels would be protected
because of they already on housing
benefits and if they're on housing
benefits presumably they're only paying
five percent
council tax anyway is that right they're
protected what's the rate
yes so housing benefit of the pensioners
can get up to 100 support uh working age
up to 95 depending on circumstances
so i hope that answers council davis's
question i mean obviously
we we are having having to take a re
responsible fiscal position
in where our housing stock we want to
maintain our houses in a good condition
uh we cannot do that if we do not uh if
we're not realistic and i think
to say that our rent our rents are very
very competitive and extremely good
value for money
and i think also we need to uh recognize
that um the
the rise we're proposing of 4.1 was
based on uh cpi as it was a few months
ago when it was only 3.1 cpi is now
significantly higher yeah i mean that's
the space the cbi is based on 3.1 which
is based on the september figure if it
was based now it would be 5.1 or
something and it could be even i think
it actually went up to seven
point four at the moment and predicted
to rise to about seven yeah the the
other thing i think we do need to take
into account is that um
uh
the government's now proposing a council
tax rebate of 150 pounds per annum on on
those in bans acd so
a significant number of our
residents um if they're not on housing
benefit um element of universal credit
we'll be getting that
full 150 pound reduction in their
council tax
um
any other uh council davis another
question yes sorry there's a lot of
waffle but not a real direct answer
there because it's not just those at the
very low end
of the scale that are going to find this
a real struggle but there's lots of
people working people out there who are
on not even average income that are
going to really struggle once again you
know baby as a council hitting them and
i believe you know the housing team do a
great job and they obviously need the
money to be able to do that but i think
we've got enough money within baber not
to have to charge as high a rate as we
have as we are doing on this as well as
the council tax
but as i did point out um those people
that you're referring to will be
benefiting from the council tax rebates
you're making are there any other
questions at this stage
counselor busby
so i seem to be obsessed with interest
payments this
uh in the
chart on page 88
i think i know the answer but the
interest payable is staying exactly the
same between the two years is that
because it's all
fixed up on a 50-year
long term
what's it
yeah that's the amount of money that we
borrowed from um the uh public works
loan board i think it was when we had to
buy do you remember we had to pay 88
million pounds for our to transfer it um
to us um which was part of that so that
is a fixed term loan and that is um
well it's just fixed for the whole term
good thank you
counselor arty
yeah i just wonder if somebody could
point me to where this garage working i
mean it's obviously as counsellor um
i think it was councillor barrett said
there's there's no particular line for
it and councillor osborne said that it's
in here somewhere um but it is
identified separately so i just wondered
if somebody could point me to which one
of these lines
it's in
yes thanks chair um thank you councillor
for the question um the work in relation
to uh reviewing our garage sites looking
at their potential
uh development or or remedial works to
to improve those areas you'll recall we
have discussed um as part of the
development of the hra business plan um
the actual work going on to to undertake
that review and assess
occupancy rates versus
versus the condition of those garages is
a piece of work being undertaken
in conjunction with the housing
directorate and the assets and
investment directorate you don't see it
in the budget in regards to
potentially additional capital
expenditure or reduced rents
because it's not in that that regard
being considered in that way as proposal
will come forward for those sites
they'll be they'll be taken
by by officers or members accordingly as
and when presented with with options so
but typically if a particular garage
site needed significant remedial works
or capital improvements it would come
out of that building services budget as
an example
okay thanks and recent discussions that
we've had on um the possible provision
of additional parking
would that be treated in the same way
yes um so this is a budget for the next
financial year it is not looking um at
the next four years because that's part
of of the hra business plan development
work that we've been undertaking some of
the scenario-based work that we have
been undertaking and what will be
represented to members in due course is
some of those scenarios around
there's a cost implication of clearly
demolishing a garage there's the
implication of lost rent for that garage
and then there's the assumption of a
potential capital improvement so
much of that and and the the detail of
that will be presented through the
business plan
okay so i take it thanks for that answer
um so i take it that what you're saying
is we are continuing to look at the
garage sites and continuing to look at
the issue of parking on some of our
council estates but that nothing is
actually going to happen for at least 12
months
and that it may be
some sort of
funding in the following years budget 23
24
that
might set some money aside for that work
the actual physical work on the ground
possibly i mean possibly if there is a
particular site which is identified
now or going forward and occupancy rates
are very very low and there's a
significant cost in in terms of
remediating that site
and we know that there's housing need in
that area and there is additional or
there's sufficient funds within the
capital programme
then much of that work can can begin now
in earnest and and is already uh being
being undertaken um i'm sure what we can
bring back to members in the not too
distant future is a review of all of
those garrisons to give you some
overlays in terms of these are where
they are these what occupancy rates are
these are our plans for for each of
those sites and this is what it means to
the bottom line in terms of potentially
reduced income or additional uh
expenditure in terms of improvements
so can i come back on that you said work
could begin if there's sufficient
funding in the capital program but
really that was my first question that
there is no funding in the capital
programme for those works is that
i think it would come out of the general
hr fund if they're identified they'll
just be come forward there's plenty of
money in the hra to divert it to a
program if we decided that
a set of garages were no longer required
for garages and they could be
redeveloped for housing then that comes
out of the general capital program for
redevelopment so it's within the budget
anyway right but would be subject to a
separate paper to us for approval
um
not necessarily because the cornered
ones that you saw came through went
through to
went through the planning without
anything coming to cabinet
um
that is the case
right and it's exactly the same sorry
that it's exactly the same whether it's
a piece of land or a piece of garage it
doesn't matter if if
if the hra identify
that there's a potential for um that
going forward it's within their budget
they do i don't think they have to come
to cabin to get it approved because
they've got it the executive it's been
um devolved or
delegated to the officers to make those
decisions
i'm pretty right now not again yeah i am
okay um
i have some questions actually just
three and i think that they're better
directed to either the cabinet member
for housing or the assistant director
firstly are we still paying for any
hotel accommodation for
uh in terms of temporary accommodation
that's the first question
that the second one we say the valuation
of our housing stock is um based on 38
of market value um
where does that 38 figure come from why
do we use that that number
and lastly
on the right to buy receipts
are we confident that we will be able to
use all of our right to buy receipts
without having to
return any to government
those are three questions councillor
osborne thank you mr chairman i'll take
your questions in reverse if i may on
the first one for the right to buy um
we are not getting quite as many right
to buy sales as we were hoping for
although it did pick up again in 21 22
with 21 sales
the amount of the right to buy receipts
available to use is 2.9 million
and it may sound like bad news but in
actual fact it's very good news is that
we've
got receipts used towards new builds and
purchases in the year is
3.34 million
so there's no risk of us having to give
any money back to the government and of
course the the time has um increased now
from the up um
from three years to five years where we
need to spend it so that's a big
advantage um your second question i will
refer to either gavin or to catherine
but on the hotel costs that actually
comes out of the general fund and not
not the hra
thank you councillor osborne
gavin or catherine do you have a
response on 38 please
we were just quickly trying to find
where where that guidance is set down it
it is a we're not sure if it's in the
accounting code of practice that we have
to follow so we may just have to follow
that up and and come back to cabinet as
to exactly you know where the guidance
is around the 38 that we use
thank you catherine that's great thank
you are there any other questions any
anyone
in which case um i'll ask council
mclaren do you have any questions on the
hra budget oh thank you chair
then
i'll move into debate does anyone have
any comments they wish to make about
this in in the debating section or have
we already discussed everything we want
to
okay um counselor barrett do you have
anything to say
um one of one of the things i think we
as a council we we ought to identify is
that quite a few um large carry forwards
each year which really does indicate
that we're not spending at the rate we
should be spending and i would like to
see and hope that those carry forwards
are reduced
which it basically means that we are
then delivering um in the hra um
obviously in the last two years it has
been difficult we've had lots of
issues with kobe which has meant uh we
haven't been able to proceed as quickly
as you are but i i would like to think
that um going forward with the money
we've got allocated a healthy hra what
we really want to be looking at is
delivering housing for our
residents that are on waiting lists and
that would be really good so i think
that's something we need to to
concentrate on and hopefully so in a
couple years time we'll be looking at
those carry forwards being substantially
reduced but the numbers of houses
delivered up
thank you council barrett
right i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
please
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress
councilman for
all four
that's laffy are you
thank you members chair that's nine
votes four and one against thank you
claire
right moving on then item 10 paper
bca2137
business rates relief policies i'll now
invite the cabinet member for finance to
to introduce this report council barrett
hmm through on a trial
so um
yeah this has come before you uh it's
due to the government
covered
rig or
compensation rules that are coming
forward to help businesses
suffer the last
restrictions which were introduced in
december have now been removed
but this is for us
as the
relevant collector of local
taxes business rates etc to then
distribute this out we are the
administrator of this
uh it's been devolved to us from central
government um because if they had to do
it there's have to have primary
legislation uh we as the collecting
authority can do it as an amendment and
this is based on what that is
so
we are asked to vote and you have the
recommendations in front of you
recommendations three three point one
three point two three point three and
three point four
um
and if uh you would i'd like that uh
propose though please
can i have a seconder
thank you castle mccraw are you
seconding yep thank you
questions anyone
does anyone have any questions
yes i have one
that's awesome
are we able to cap this in that if um
if some of these uh
leisure hospitality are given funding
and then within a short period of part
time they no longer exist and i'm
thinking along the lines here
in particular i'll say like bed and
breakfast
um where they were given quite large
sums
um
are we able to cap this all
somehow so that we don't get any sort of
or is there any due diligence on this
um i'm not quite sure how it works in
that aspect
andrew are you able to respond to that
please yes councillor dawson in terms of
the retail discount the 50 is what the
government are recommended as the value
we pass across and they will fund that
that will only change if the business
does fail we will apportion the accounts
or abortions value that's given to them
so
as far as we can cap it really
thank you andrew
any other questions
um i'll ask other
members of the council um if they wish
to have any questions council mclaren or
councillor osmond or councillor barrett
right
okay we'll move into the debate does
anyone have any comments i wish to make
about this i mean uh i think as council
barrett has has indicated that this is
fairly straightforward these uh policies
that we're implementing but the
government is is funding um
the the details are quite clear in the
paper that we have here um
and um
it's all part of the the ongoing support
um excellent support that has been
provided to our businesses so um uh
i i think
from from my point of view it's um
it's a paper that we we definitely want
to approve does anyone
wish to make any other comments
councillor holt
yeah i'd just like to say from the
information i've been given this isn't
the easiest of
things to implement and um
i think it's taken a lot of work from
andrew's team to come up with some sort
of options to be presented to us
um so i'd just be mindful for members to
just be patient and
um it's it's not as straightforward as
it may seem so long and say
thank you councillor
castleberry
um as we're getting to the end i'd just
like to as a end of my sort of three
papers um uh and also the end of
catherine's um
budget proposals for
when she's actually presenting just like
to say thank you for the her and her
team rebecca
melissa and catherine um helping me in
my first
budget putting forward um been very
helpful and been
very uh
informative and i hope
we've produced a good budget together
for everyone so thank you for that
you council barrett and uh not just a
good budget for your first but uh also a
good one for catherine's last
and um
uh and we do want to thank you very much
for all the work that you've
done for us and uh steering us through
our finances over the years thank you
councilman crawl
thanks uh chair i'd just like to draw
members attention to a couple of things
i mean the
leisure hospitality and retail areas in
the last two years have had a nightmare
i know there have been so many grants
flying around it's been very difficult
for those businesses to keep track of
which applications are available some
have been awarded automatically
some have to be reapplied for
due diligence on these is done in every
occasion i know because i've dealt with
a number of cases in my own ward
i'd just like to draw attention from
members that we've been allocated 1.7
million
um
at the end of the period
at the end of the year there will be a
reconciliation
process any unspent funding will be
returned to government so i just like to
draw people's attention to the fact that
we don't really want there to be any
unspent funding um
that's all
thank you council crawl fair point
okay then i will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic mode
please
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress
council on the court
thank you
thank you members chair that's 10 votes
for thanksgiving
moving on item 11 paper bca2138 the
accommodation and agile strategy
relating to endeavor house i'll now
invite the cabinet member for assets and
investments to introduce this report
council busby
thank you chair
i'm pleased to be presenting this report
today as part of our journey to deliver
truly collaborative forward-looking
workspaces for our staff and councillors
to enable them
to best serve our communities and
residents
working through the last two years has
taught us many things
the officer and counsellor working
groups have considered the best ways of
working
and the way to maximize the use of our
working space
in addition our staff survey showed that
70 percent of staff believed they could
be most effective by working in a hybrid
way
coming into the office for no more than
three days per week to collaborate with
colleagues and partners for their own
well-being
by considering this alongside our
occupational survey prior to the
pandemic we can reduce our overall floor
space within endeavour house and use
these savings to deliver truly
collaborative and inspiring workspace
for our organizations whilst also
delivering a net saving of approximately
three hundred thousand pounds per
council and reducing our impact impact
on the environment by reducing travel
this project will deliver a creative
flexible working space for staff and
counsellors as we return to more
face-to-face working
of course it will bring new challenges
in managing time and
availability we recognize that things
have not been perfect over the last two
years where we have been working more
remotely than we would prefer
so alongside flexibility must come some
discipline and regularity
a free for all will not work for
councillors or residents not everyone
can would want to opt to work from home
on a monday and friday for example
however it is important that we look
forward and deliver the most suitable
workspace for our people as they
continue to work hard for our residents
whether that is in the office from home
or across our districts
i'm excited to see this vision being
delivered and to see how this supports
and transforms our organizations as we
continue to focus on serving our
residents
you've got the recommendations on the
paper
i'll propose those thank you
thank you council busby may i have a
second to please
i'd be happy to second this
so questions from counsellors anyone
have any questions for council busby
um when i read the report um i mean it's
obviously very detailed
um
what i was slightly concerned about is
the fact that the report is just looking
at and we're only looking at
square footage
but actually it's deeper than that isn't
it because it's actually looking at the
way the council operates
and i wonder whether that came across in
the port quite enough i mean it's
literally just desks
nice area what about the staff there's
not enough touchy feely in it which is a
bit unusual for a baby report
so i think if you look at the
actual
proposed layout and the types of
furniture that we're looking forward to
bringing in it actually does resolve
that issue it's they aren't just desks
there are places where there are all
kinds of a variety of working spaces and
uh collaborative areas so that people
can get together in informal meetings
and formal meetings
council hall
i've got great concerns about this i
have to say
i just feel that as an organization
we are
going down a path that members haven't
had time to discuss or debate
i really do think this is something that
should have gone to full council for all
members
to discuss
um
i am not particularly
at ease with the number of deaths that
will be available for the amount of
staff that we have
i'm not at ease with this presumption
that um it's it's
better and for the better of the
well-being to be working from home
um
i think as an organization we need to
set ourselves apart
we are unique in what we are
and i believe teamwork is key to having
an effective
council
and our officers work in teams
um
previously going into endeavour house
prior pandemic if you walked into the
planning team you would have a group of
planners there you would have a group of
housing officers there if you walked in
the housing team
they would look over one another's
shoulder talk to the to their colleagues
discuss certain issues with potential
cases they had
planners would do the same
um and i just feel that we are going
away from that emphasis of team
working together
um and i
i just can't
agree with this as it's written here i
think we're reducing
our death space by far too much
i think there is a presumption these
days after the pandemic that you will
work from home
i think there is a presumption that
people have the ability to work from
home
and i think there's
not enough evidence yet to say that the
well-being of people who do end up
working from home
is
the long is in the long term beneficial
to them the isolation
that people suffer from working at home
we're assuming that people's
circumstances allow them to do so into
in some comfort
not everyone will have a room where they
can go to set up a desk and set up an
office
if you're working from a bedroom or a
dining room or a lounge where you've got
children
i don't think there's enough evidence or
enough
studies done yet to prove one way or
another the benefits or the
if there are benefits from working at
home
so
i would i just think we're running ahead
with this we've got a a target date
which is
set in our lease
as a break clause
um i think
to carry out this type of work over a
pandemic
has perhaps presented
some falsehoods in the way that officers
want to work in the future
i just feel as members we are the you
know we are running a business
we are all directors of this business
all members
and we need a collaborative say amongst
ourselves how we think this organization
needs to work
and obviously arthur is the head of
service and he then implements that and
i just feel that this is coming far too
soon
and i do have
concerns as to say how this will affect
the organization going forward
and that's what i want to say at the
moment
okay thank you council hulk the
councilmember vc and then council davis
um
if these are
stick i know castle holt um moved into
debate but um
we are still in question so is this a
question
yeah if it's debate then we'll we'll
wait
my question is um
i believe there's a staff survey
recently completed or
about to be completed was that included
in this paper or with the results of
that included
council buzzfeed do you have an answer
to that
or
emily
good afternoon so um there have been a
number of surveys undertaken so the
first one was undertaken in october 2019
before
the pandemic
and that was a physical survey to see
which desks were being used within the
building
and
and was quite fortuitous i suppose in
terms of timing
the subsequent um surveys have been held
with um
staff members to see
what kinds of working practices they
would like to engage in moving forward
so we had a response rate of over 200
people
with i think over 70 percent of people
saying that they would like to either
come into the office on an ad hoc basis
or for one two or three days a week
so
and the majority of respondents said the
reasons they wanted to come into the
office were to collaborate and for their
well-being
and we've taken all of that survey data
into account in terms of designing the
floor plate
and the thinking behind
this program
so that
we've tried to design a floor plate that
will help to facilitate a true
collaboration rather than just sitting
next to each other teams will be able to
book banks of desks and workspaces
together so that they can work in a
truly collaborative way and we've tried
to design a space that will be
um
that will encourage people to come back
into the office having spent um the last
couple of years working uh in a sort of
remote um manner so that's the sort of
ethos behind um
behind the program to try to encourage
people back in and to provide the kind
of spaces that we really need in order
to be able to work effectively in a
collaborative way
rather than it just being banks of desks
which are very traditional
sort of office layouts and don't
necessarily um promote collaborative
working in the ways that we would like
to work moving forward
thank you emily
castlevari
um
emily could you just confirm so the um
illustrate or the
site plan
gold floor one
is that the only
space that will be in this building
that would be exclusively for us
thank you so yes the intention is to
reduce from
and we have the gold floor plate and the
lime floor plates currently we have
around about 260 working spaces if you
include the meeting rooms
within our floor plates we're looking to
reduce that capacity to around about 60
percent
which aligns with um
the occupational survey that we
undertook in 2019
which showed that pre-pandemic we were
using around about 60 of our spaces
and
so yes
the intention is for us to just have a
lease of the gold floor plate out on the
first floor
obviously part of the benefits of this
building are that we do also have access
to other areas yeah within the building
like this room etc and the other meeting
rooms the
suffolk sitting room and the breakout
spaces around the building so we'll
continue to work in that um kind of
collaborative way across the building as
well as just within our suite
i mean
what i find amazing is that we you know
four years ago
we were occupying
two large buildings one in hadley one in
needham market and we're now into
this
how does this how does this work i mean
this is sort of like harry potter risk
isn't it or is this the tardis
because i mean doctor who isn't it you
know you're going in and it's like a lot
bigger than when you walk through the
thing because you know you look at the
square footage that we're leaving behind
in
in uh there it just makes me wonder are
we being a bit too
uh
careful about what we're doing here
because it just seems a large reduction
of an extremely large reduction in floor
plate
my response to that uh counselor would
be that uh those those two buildings we
did have were under occupied
significantly and there was a lot of
vacant space there um
the
the although we are losing one of two
floor plates here we're using the
remaining floor plate far more
efficiently um and the actual number of
uh workstations workspaces in that floor
plate um is greater than it currently is
so we're not actually losing um
an equivalent of one floor plates worth
of space in terms of um
actual uh capacity for um individuals to
to work there
um and
as as you've heard that it is all
evidence-based it's it's based on um
staff working practices how they've
changed and they always change
i'll come back to that in in debate um
but um are there any other questions
before we go to debate i've got
councillor busby and then councillor
mccraw then councillor halt
mine's not a question it's here in
relation to councillor barrett's point
um
you've asked all of the directors to
cut the padding out of the budgets
and
go with what we think we're going to use
and that's what we've done
you can't have it both ways
no i'm not i'm not questioning whether
the uh i'm just
more concerned that um
the the the about that we had and
compared what we're looking to go to
that is very small bear in mind we had
two large buildings
staffed
albeit
you could never find anyone because
they're obviously clearly
lost in the buildings
we certainly find them here weren't we
the other problem about the the original
two buildings so some of the time you
couldn't find people is because they're
in the other building and 16 miles away
now they were on journey most of the
time or traveling between the two which
is highly inefficient we don't want to
see that again
council
macro thank you chair i
wonder how much given the speed with
which this has been brought to
everybody's attention
how much of this has been predicated the
decision-making process by the march
2022 break clause
because it appears to me that's the
reason for is the speed would it be
possible um
and how when would the changes actually
be implemented after or before march
2022 presumably
and then would it be possible given the
time frame we have before us for this if
it were
the will of the cabinet
to take it to council
for them to have a look at is there time
for that to happen
i've got some observations about the
layout but that can wait till debate
council busby do you wish to respond to
any of
those well emily can kick off i think
yeah so just in terms of um timing
and so this is certainly something that
we haven't um rushed through quickly to
meet that break date we started looking
at
um the accommodation strategy and at the
beginning of the pandemic actually we
recognized that this was a
um
a time of change and we needed to assess
um how things were changing throughout
that that period so we first looked at
the um
principles of that review
and in i think it was summer 2020 so
certainly something that hasn't been
rushed through and there's been a lot of
engagement with um with staff and also
with councillors through the different
working groups
and from a timing perspective we need to
implement our break by the end of march
that means that we're effectively
serving our six month notice period so
that the lyme floor would be handed back
um
at the end of
october time so in terms of the works
actually being undertaken what we'd look
to do
is
keep the line floor operational
whilst works the gold floor plate were
undertaken and then we'd hand back the
lime um floor plate towards the end of
um october time we have um been engaging
with our landlord throughout this
process as well
and they're happy to work with us
bearing in mind the challenges that
there are out there at the moment with
supplies and contractors etc so that's
our intended timeline but there is the
potential for
some slight variation to that
and the third part of the question about
whether it is feasible or possible to
take this to council
emily is that something you could rule
on as monitoring officer please
yes thank you chair and this would be an
executive function so it is for the
cabinet to make the decision
but of course it is at the cabinet's
discretion to refer items to the full
council for discussion uh to then inform
your decision thank you
thank you emily
and i mean don't forget
all councillors had the opportunity to
be present here today to take part in
the discussion
and some of them have been included in
the
working groups so it's not as though
this is going to come cold to everybody
if it is it's partly their their own
fault
right okay um
questions uh counselor holt you had a
question and then counselor arthi
yeah it's uh to do with emily mentioned
about staff surveys and some interesting
what's on the website
um
when asking staff how they want to work
in the future 30 of them
want to be in the workplace one day a
week
30
want to be able to visit ad hoc
just uh fewer than three percent want to
be back in the office five days a week
and yet when asked why they wanted to be
in the office almost everyone agreed
that collaboration and social
interaction was the biggest reason
an impact that had
on health and wellbeing
so
it one almost contradicts the other to a
certain extent people want to be in the
office
for their health and well-being and yet
one day a week
how are you going to get them to working
together in a collaborative way when
it's good for their health and
well-being and social interaction if
you've got such small numbers in from
various different teams
to me that sounds
opposite
of what other you know you've got people
who want to come one day a week ad hoc
but you want people
who appreciate working and interact with
one another
it doesn't quite marry up to me and i
just think
is this data which is 221 responses
is this really the 60 well 63 percent
they're referring to is it really a
reflection of how our staff are feeling
about this move potential move
look i think all of those figures are
correct um i mean for instance
yeah you might be happy meeting your
friends down the pub once a week but you
wouldn't want to meet them every day
and you wouldn't need to meet them every
day and it won't be down to the
individuals to determine
exactly where and when they're going to
be in the office it'll be down to their
manager
or director to ensure that the team
operates efficiently and to the best of
their abilities and if that means that
they come in
monday and friday for a team meeting
then they should come in monday and
friday for team meetings he won't be
then saying oh well i can't be bothered
coming in that day and we've got to give
some credit to the managers and the
directors
i agree to a certain extent but we also
as an organization have to set our goals
out quite clearly and i'm not quite sure
we are doing that
if you're going to adopt this modern
approach to working from home
we are a local authority that we owe it
to our residents to provide a service
and i think this could have an impact on
the service we provide i mean i wouldn't
criticize any of the officers at all
what they've done through this pandemic
has been absolutely amazing
but to look ahead and look forward and
work in a collaborative way i'm not sure
this is the way we should be looking in
reducing the numbers so significantly
i certainly agree that we need to be um
sharper or more aware on where people
are and there needs to be some kind of
regularity in it it's no use if uh the
person you're looking for is in on a
monday and tuesday one week and then a
wednesday and a friday the following
week then monday and thursday the week
after we need to be able to
know where they are without having to go
all the way around the houses but
that will be part of the the discipline
of this new um process and
staff
will get the benefits if it is benefit
from working from home and hybrid
working and therefore they should accept
the discipline that goes with that
i think the chief executive wants to um
comment on this arthur
thank you i just wanted to add not to
the debate because obviously it's a
matter for yourselves to to consider but
i think there may be a misconception of
this concept of whether an officer is in
endeavour house or working from home
of course that isn't a
straight choice in that regard
when we moved here in the first place
some four years ago certainly my
instruction to officers was to be
working in the districts as much as
possible conscious that this building is
outside of both districts and so
on any given occasion you may have a
planning officer for example out on site
on a different day they may be here you
may have a building control officer
coming here for meetings or out on site
and so on and so forth so you're
absolutely right we clearly have far
more people working at some points at
home driven by the pandemic
than we ever have had in the past but
just for clarity i wouldn't want members
can under their misapprehension that
it's either here or or at home it's
clearly those choices but a whole lot of
other places
as well
thank you arthur
um councillor arthur you've got a
question
yeah i've got two and the
simple ones really where do we go from
here
and should we start looking for
somewhere else
um
because that's really simple
yeah
okay
um because it seems to me i mean it was
about five years ago that we were sold
this concept of a public sector village
um and that we'd be here ipswich borough
councillor here the county council would
be here um you know getting consultation
responses out of the county council will
be an absolute doddle because they're
just upstairs
but in actual fact
i don't think that
anything has changed very much because
everything's done electronically anyway
so i don't think it would matter where
we were as long as we were well
connected
when we were looking at the the options
when
we had staff working both the joined
staff
working both in need and market and
hadley i think the cheapest option of
all was for everybody to relocate to
hadley
and the thought then was that it would
require loads of work would be expensive
um and probably wouldn't be big enough
i think now you can see that perhaps the
old maltings buildings in hadley would
have been big enough and we and we'd
have a council chamber
so i wonder where we ought to
be looking long term
um
it seems to me that we don't actually
need anywhere near the space that we did
before
it seems to me that we're a little bit
short of access to
the council chamber
if we call this chamber our council
chamber
and meeting rooms they always seem to be
booked
and i really do wonder if we're going to
continue to work with mid-suffolk
whether we ought to be looking to
relocate to somewhere
kind of on the border if you like
between baber and mid-suffolk
even spanning the border would be quite
cute
um and that that's that's where we ought
to um be looking to to work from so
you're kind of looking at the the
brantford blakenham um
sort of area i suppose um
because i it seems to me that
this hasn't been
quite the success
um i think it was sold to us by
strangely enough the chief exec of the
county council who had a bit of space
left over here and wanted a good
occupier
and she was our interim chief exec at
the same time
i don't know if the arguments were
particularly strong
and i don't think that looking forward
it's a solution for evermore so
sure i i agree with dave i don't
disagree with his report and i'll
support it that it's it's saving us a
little bit of money and it's probably um
you know slightly different way of
working that we should accept
but i think in the long term we've got
to look at where we as a council
ought to be and i don't think there's a
requirement to be here i think the
concept of the public sector village is
lost
um
that that's history now even though it
was only five years ago
and i think we actually ought to be
looking to get some identity back
thank you
thank you for that can i respond respond
to that marthy yeah
this is kind of moving into debate you
can't uh respond but i just want to just
check are there any questions from
anyone first before
you respond to that because i want to
respond to that as well um
two questions councillor osborne will be
the last one cabinet and then i'll
council mclaren
councillor osborne thank you mr chairman
um yeah as we're in questions can i just
have clarification on the number of
desks being allocated will that
accommodate
a three-day working week in endeavour
house
or have those desks been assigned for on
the principle of a one-day working week
in endeavor house if i could just have i
would like to go when we go into debate
but that's my question
so we took the data from the survey
um and extrapolated that so we looked at
the percentages of the people who wanted
to work one day a week two days a week
three days a week four days a week five
days a week and and that was how we
came to our fixed desks
of around about 45 desks i think we've
got about 48 desks
on our plan so the number of desks isn't
predicated on a one day a week a two day
a week a three day a week it's a blend
depending on the returns that we had
from our survey and we've probably erred
more towards the cautious so we've
included more desks than the survey
necessarily indicated
rather than fewer deaths so we've
rounded up rather than rounded down as
it were
thank you emily um
sorry castle dawson you have a question
i have yes oh okay
um what i've been trying to ask is
if uh and i concur with many things
clive is saying and michael hold but if
here um
there was which i believe there should
be a minimum three days if not four days
i mean we're a service industry and i
think the idea that people want to spend
one day here it's just a nonsense but if
this was three or four days
um taking into account how you've done
the analysis
how would this then look then
how many desks you know you've got to
the reality is if there's 212 people
if they're coming in three to four days
this would look very different wouldn't
it and that's really where we should be
so
i think we have to um look at how we
have worked since we've been in
endeavour house so we have had an agile
approach to working since we've been in
deva house so some people may have
worked in the office five days a week
some people may have may not have come
in at all so when we looked at um
the number of desks and the spaces we
needed to provide we did look very
closely at the occupation levels that
we'd assessed through the two-week
survey that we undertook in 2019
the number of working spaces has reduced
by about 40 percent which actually
reflects
the
levels of occupation we had in 2019
so if people continue to work in the way
they were working in 2019 when they come
back then there ought to still be
enough workspaces for them there's a
choice of workspaces so it's not all
traditional desks there will be other
forms of desks that people can work at
um
yes but what you're saying is that if
since prior to 2019
obviously kovids come along and they're
working differently if there are people
like the going out to do the trees they
don't need to be in the office i
understand that but we shouldn't be
having this um
what is being pushed through here that
people think oh i want to work at home
and therefore i just don't understand it
we're in a service industry and you know
it is
from personally i find incredibly
difficult um to engage
to be because they're always in
different places so again
should of these 212 people
it's your personal opinion that you
don't think taking taking covid because
we're coming out of that and you can see
the reluctance in central government
government workers don't want to come
back into the office
but we are a service industry so it's
not really about
and i understand the agile working
but it's not really about what people
want it's what baber needs to be giving
to our residents and the perception of
the residents
is at the moment
these people and i'm sort of getting
that slight impression from you as well
that you're encouraging people not to
come back here this this is what seems
to be coming over to me anyway and and i
think that's the kind of um
misconception around this this project
this project isn't about telling people
to work from home in the future
it's about people making the right
choices about where to undertake the
tasks that they're trying to undertake
so if they've got a report or a complex
document that they need to read and
actually they need to work in in in
peace and quiet then it may be that
they're better placed at home but then
wouldn't then according to your agile
environment here wouldn't these be
people sitting in a small room i mean
they should be setting examples to the
teams they shouldn't really all be at
home
i i think the reality is that our
officers work really hard and
effectively no i don't understand
absolutely sure they do across a range
of different accommodation settings one
of those accommodation settings is
endeavour house and what we're proposing
to do is invest it and make it a more
inviting place to come and work on one
that's more suitable for the
collaboration that everybody in this
room and also our members of staff have
said is so important to them so that's
what we're trying to achieve in life we
also hope we're also empowering our
managers to have discussions with their
teams to ensure that we're delivering
the best services we can so for some
teams that will mean they need to be
more present than others and it's about
having the ability
to um
use our spaces most effectively and
efficiently and for those teams that
need more time in the office they will
have more time available rather than
having a kind of fixed rule that says
you must be in the office three days a
week for some officers as arthur
mentioned they may be out on site three
days a week so can you just confirm to
me then if there's 212 people i think it
is here
60 of those come in three or four days a
week
can they
sit out and not an adjunct you know not
can they sit and work at a desk or you
saying they can't
so the the concept plan shows a range of
different working spaces from the
traditional desk through to
um
some of the
uh sort of quietest they've actually got
48 desks here i think it is
a seated desk so that says to me any one
time someone wants to 48 people can
actually sit and work at a desk now if
you've got 212 people that means there's
really only seating proper proper
seating
for 25
people and we have to assume then the
other
35 40 that might be coming or will be
working agile um you know
the the other workspaces are still
workspaces so i think we shouldn't um we
shouldn't think you can only work from a
traditional desk
and some of the agile spaces
collaboration spaces that are included
within the floor plate are meant to
actually help teams work better together
so over the
you know the prior to the pandemic
people would come into the office and
sit wherever there is a space we're
looking to actually try to make
collaboration easier so that whether
it's service teams or project teams they
can book a bank of desks together or a
group of desks together they may also be
more inward-facing rather than in a
straight line which is our
you know the formation of our
traditional desks so i certainly
wouldn't say that the
concept plan only allows for 48 people
to be working you know we'd expect to
see a much higher number of people
working equally we're not saying that
every single chair within the building
will be fully occupied there will be
spaces that are kind of transition
spaces where people do pop and have a
quick meeting for five or ten minutes or
they touch down at a space in between a
formal meeting
i was just wondering and it just follows
on from some of the concepts introduced
by councillor dawson and it's about
practical arrangements and i think it's
perfectly reasonable to ask questions
about practical arrangements so we've
got
48 hot desks which sort of classic thing
we think of as a desk in that layout and
i have to confess i find the the ones we
have at the moment they are a little bit
intimidating as they are
um we have 68 um
places in what's called the agile
working environment which is
yeah i'm sort of trying to work out
exactly where the agility comes in 46 in
meeting spaces and i understand what a
meeting space is it's in its enclosed
room
and i do like the fact that sound
proofing will be provided with this
potential proposal
um but i'm just wondering
out of those
positions all being had we have to also
to remember that there are going to be
occasionally counsellors are going to
come into the meetings and the offices
and we might want to use some of the
meeting rooms so has that been taken
into account that um that and of course
everything is a it's a movable feast you
know we've got the breakout areas we've
got all that sort of stuff it's not as
though we are confined to our own little
ghetto at least i hope not so my
questions really are about these
practical arrangements in all the spaces
the 48 the 68 and the 46
will all the services be available to
make them useful working spaces
in relation to the meeting rooms again
we looked at meeting room usage during
the same period of time that we assessed
desk usage and and again that showed
that around about 60 of our room
capacity was being used so that was
based on bookings not based on staff
numbers so that would have included any
bookings that councillors
had made
within those spaces as well which in
reality was possibly through members of
staff in any event so yes that 60 usage
of um
room booking capacity um considers
everybody not just staff it is also
councillors
and there will be a range of different
opportunities and ways of working
across the
floor plate to meet the needs of both
staff and counsellors including
providing as you mentioned the the the
soundproof meeting rooms we've looked to
increase the capacity and size of some
of the meeting rooms so we've removed
some of the smaller rooms that were a
little bit more
restricted in use and actually replace
those with some larger capacity rooms
which
will be um
more flexible because obviously you can
still have small meetings in those rooms
but you can't have large meetings in the
smaller rooms so
um
i hope that helps just give a bit of
clarity
okay um uh thank you for that emily um i
would like to just
pause for a few minutes and uh suspend
the the meeting um alyssia can you
switch off the
thank you um welcome back everyone after
our little break um we're still in
questions on on this item but there are
only two other questions from other
members of the uh council uh i have a
question from councillor mclaren and
also councilman melanie barrett so
council mclaren first thank you chair
um
i am going to ask a question but i just
want to make a comment um
that i believe we're still in
pandemic mode
and i think we've no idea what the
future is going to hold
and um
i think that influences how people
respond to
homework in or working away but my
question is
if
we go ahead with this
what is the fallback position
if we've actually got it wrong
and in a couple of years time
we actually need more space so
what what are the arrangements for that
thank you chair
thank you council mclaren that's
actually quite a valid question emily do
you have a response please thank you
thank you for that question
and so i think we are saying with this
project that this is um where we think
we will need to be now and potentially
moving into the future but we're also
acknowledging that things are changing
quite quickly
and it's very difficult to predict uh
long-term you know what our requirements
are going to be so i think that you know
that's a really fair comment um in terms
of flexibility we do have a really good
relationship with the county council um
so if we were looking to take more space
if there was more space available within
this building in the future i'm sure
that would be an option for us
and in addition the layout of the
concept plan
does show um fixed desks in in some
locations and then more agile spaces in
others
i think one of the benefits of this plan
is that um it is largely furniture
so if we find that certain styles of
furniture are more popular than others
then we can change that and adapt um in
the future and we can use any surplus
furniture um within other um
other operational buildings like our
depots or touchdown points as well so
there is a degree of flexibility in in
the plan and i think we all accept that
how we work now how we work in the
future is something that is evolving
it's moving quite quickly and this is
our best assessment at this point in
time as to what we need as an
organisation moving forward
thank you emily thank you
thank you
councillor barrett
thank you chair um
firstly i'd just like to say that i was
part of that working committee um
laterally in the latter stages and
joined emily and her team on that
and in fact i did express some
reservations about the move
um but i mean i i think we all recognize
that
uh hybrid working as we with the new
term for for part home part office
that's here to stay um
covert has accelerated i i guess um
because we've all been uh
got got the technology to support it uh
to a greater extent so
if we accept that i think what we're out
arguing about is the balance
how much
is
suitable for working away from the
office and how much
is uh the
attendance at the office an essential
and it's getting that that percentage
correct and i think that's what the
concerns have been expressed i've heard
this afternoon in a way
um
we
we know there's negative
there there's some negative potentials
for negative um
creeping in if we have too much home
working i've looked at a lot of studies
i i'm
i'm
able to access sort of professional
sites to look at the what the studies
are finding and that they're identifying
lots of opportunity for collaboration
with colleagues weakened work
relationships affecting innovation
um less opportunity to to train on the
job um
lower profile of senior staff i think
that's that's quite a
an important one that doesn't get
recognized very much um isolation
um
so
it and and i'm looking at the report
also i didn't i didn't think the report
really addressed any of that i mean we
we're used to having our reports
presented to us and having the risks
and then the the measures to sort of
mitigate those risks now the risks in
this report were solely about
the the physical environment and did we
had we got it right on that those
aspects but not really about
those aspects of um impact on working
relationships at work
that these areas that it's quite risky
if you lose that it's quite a big risk
to your organization
because
we know that organizations that with
dispersed staff where they can't be
based in the same office
their communication
suffers they find it very difficult to
communicate with all their staff
and it presents them a real challenge
and if you don't have good communication
with your staff
then it's it's quite damaging
so i just think
i was pleased to hear council busby you
just spoke earlier about um um
did you say a maximum of three days no
more than three days a week and i
really wouldn't like to see it go go
below three days a week and i know emily
has said some people have expressed sort
of
perhaps
seeing themselves doing one two days a
week but i think that that over a long
period
is a different prospect to seeing over a
pandemic
it's it's only it's it's still still
early stages to assess whether that has
been totally um
successful or not i don't think we know
yet and i i believe that because during
the pandemic we had a lot of established
staff who knew their colleagues knew
their work
didn't need the level of innovate uh
collaboration with their colleagues that
newer members of staff who are joining
you
now and you know in the future they
won't benefit from that level of
communication that your previous staff
did
so i think that's a really um
essential thing to consider so then that
moves through to thinking about the
number of desks
so 48 fixed desks
is an incredible prospect it's so low
because i think as an organization you
would want to respect
the individuals who wanted to be in the
office 100
there will be some more junior people
more
people who live alone perhaps
people who suffer from uh feeling
isolation they will probably opt to be
here a hundred percent
so that takes out a certain amount of
those 48 desks um so what what might you
be left with i don't know whether you've
been able to to look at those figures if
that was 35 desks
for your whole organization
so looking at that scenario and looking
also the flexibility that that that
takes away from you so you've got 48
desks
does that mean that when
this team comes this team member comes
in
can they sit with their other planning
colleagues or are all those deaths
you know
is that not possible because there's a
lack of flexibility with just 48.
also if an officer is not due to come in
that day you know you've talked about
a structured approach to it not being
just a a free-for-all if he's not if
that person is not jim but something
what worked comes up and it means that
they they need to be in in the office
can they or are they gonna
find it really struggle to to find a
working space
um
so i think that that that gives us quite
a quite an inflexible um situation with
just 48 desks so i think on the the
number of days is essential to it to
establish what your minimum is before it
really impacts on your working
um and the split of desks um
and as councillor mclaren has alluded to
well what in the future if we find that
we
we've got it a bit wrong the split is is
is uh too much to the collaborative
well we've already committed to those
deaths so that's quite an expense and i
was surprised to see
500
allocated that's that's a lot of money
that that seems like you know a lot to
gamble on this when we're still just
coming out of this this um
this period where home working has been
a bit of an experiment that we've had to
adopt
um
so
thank you councillor um unconscious
um
we'll we'll uh pass on on on that and
there were some valid points from
somebody who was um on the the working
group so
um i was prepared to
to allow all that to be said and because
they are important points um we are now
moving into debate i think although
we've had quite a bit of debates i doubt
there's going to be much more but i just
want to say a few things myself
i don't uh firstly i'm councillor arthea
i take the points you're making but i
don't see any benefit in re-opening the
debate that we had five years ago when
we looked at the options for the future
location
of our two councils
i i disagree with being here has been a
success
the public sector hub that we've got
here is is still a valid proposition
and this is a modern office building not
only is is it modern it's it provides a
pleasant working environment for our for
our staff and it can be reconfigured to
be a flexible agile and collaborative
workspace as we've heard um unlike uh
our previous buildings
and it's also convenient for most of our
staff who do converge on on it from all
directions and stuff again indeed
further afield i think the idea of
relocating is fast forward
we would have to build new premises
wherever they are at huge expense
and where would it be which council area
which town i know you talked about
somewhere on the boundaries straddling
the two but nonetheless the cost would
be prohibitive um and these are the same
old questions that really were addressed
when we discounted um
a new build before um that the reasons
for endeavour house five years ago
uh are just as valid now as they they
were then um
[Music]
the question is
i think
are we reconfiguring the space we've got
here um in a way that is going to be fit
for the future clearly the the layout
we've had was was fine for five years
ago and but
as as always
anything to do with the office
environment
if the last i don't know 20 30 40 years
have taught us anything it's that office
environments change and they change
quite rapidly over that period um i've
i've been working uh working in in a
large office environment now since since
1981
admittedly um
i retired four years ago but i'm still
counting this as working in an office
environment and i've seen those changes
and i've seen the reasons for those
changes and and uh and that's still
happening now um we're seeing that uh
organizations in the private and public
sector
are increasingly moving to this um more
agile and uh
and flexible environment and what we've
got here with a mixture of fixed desks
uh workspaces and and others is exactly
what's going to be required going
forward we don't want banks of desks for
everyone that's not how people work
these days it's not how they want to
work yeah we need to focus on on the
well-being of our staff and and
as has been quite rightly pointed out a
number of people are going to want to
spend
more on
most
i'd say
yeah probably most of their time here in
the office rather than at home and and
um and that's that's fine the the
proposals we've got here will allow for
that
it will allow for
individuals and teams to work in the way
that suits them best
um
yeah we do want to make sure that it's
structured rather than a free-for-all we
don't want people just sort of
willy-nilly turning up left right and
center and it needs to be organized but
um
i think that
through the surveys that have been uh
undertaken not just in in 2019 but also
monitoring how people have used this
office since we moved here in 2017
shows that the
a reduction in the
total um
number of work stations that we provide
is is a valid proposition and it won't
impact and
deter people from coming here should
they wish to
and we are providing that mix of
different kinds of work environment that
that's increasingly going to be required
so
i think that
the proposals we have here have been
thought through they are evidence-based
um and we just need to show that it will
work um and and you have heard that um
should we find in response to council
mclaren's question should we find that
in a year's time we do need some some
additional space then then that can
probably be negotiated with the county
council and i don't see no reason why
not um but we do need to make changes we
can't just keep working in the way we
did five years ago or 10 years ago or
even 30 40 years ago uh things things
have changed and and uh i i think that
what we've got here is
is um
something that
our staff will really
like and appreciate when when it's
implemented and i think all of us will
all of us as counselors will i think we
just got to
to uh to give it a chance to work
so that's all i want to say on on the
subject um
councillor davis
thank you yeah um i think the first
thing i'll say which i wasn't going to
but you brought it up as well i don't
think um councillor arthur's point about
uh moving out of hadley as a is fantable
or you know building a new building you
know the fact is nine years ago five
years ago when we moved out of there
you know you would say you know we
should forget that because you were part
of the conservative administration that
forced us out of hadley you know to
leave our district and come into ipswich
five years ago we didn't know for
example i mean neither need a market
they've sold their building they've
built on it they've made a profit ours
is still empty and boarded up you know
that that had a more detrimental effect
on high street businesses in in the
district and in hadley than reducing car
parking charges to an hour or reducing
free car parking to an hour so it's had
far more than that yeah i know you don't
want to hear it because you forced to
move through it but there you go but
also the councillors are the council
arthur is absolutely right let's why not
have explore the option of building a
purpose-built building not just for
ourselves but that we can make it as an
investment in the district longer term
now we're here now so that's one of the
things but if people cast their mind
back just be pre-pandemic how often
would you come in when when people did
come in and find rows and rows of empty
desks you know along the two floors they
weren't always full the meeting rooms
were quite often empty our
council room for example that our
working area
you know you and susie probably in there
more than anybody else and most of the
time it was empty so i think it's
absolutely right now that we're here to
consolidate down to the one floor i
disagree
also i agree with um what uh emily has
said about and arthur what made the
point it's not a case of you know black
and white you're either working from
home or you're working in the office a
lot of our officers are out in the field
a lot of the time you know and i'll just
go with my team for example my portfolio
i trust
the corporate manager and the ad
implicitly to manage their workforce to
manage their team to be able to say to
them yes it's the right thing for baber
the right thing for the communities team
for you to come in one day a week two
days a week or whatever it is because
they know they know their workload they
know their people and i've spoken to
some of the team members and some would
prefer to be in the office more often
give them that opportunity but some
going out to do the community grants
probably out all day you know they don't
need to come in the office and also when
it comes to team building someone make a
very good point about that absolutely
and they have weighed 18 days you know
i've been with them too like long
melford for example they're going on
another one soon so the newer members
are assimilated into the team
so absolutely that's right and we need
as baba as a council we need to get bit
you know with move with the times modern
way of working it works everywhere a lot
of places you know the bigger companies
are consolidating yeah they're either
selling their buildings or they're
downsizing you know and i'm not
suggesting that we have table tennis
racquets and you know table football in
in there like you know quite a lot of
the companies that are moving forward in
terms of the mental wealth of that but
of their teams of their workforce amazon
for example you know it's a completely
different world i think it's absolutely
right so i commend this report i think
it's a good job and uh and and i'll
certainly be supporting it
i think council dave just a last comment
on court's lane um
there have been some rather lengthy
planning issues to resolve the final
planning matters were approved last week
and so we're now in a position to
proceed this year with the redevelopment
of the courts lane side it has taken us
longer than anticipated but we we are in
uh the process of being able to do that
um
council busby
thanks jim um yeah looking forward i
mean five years hence we could move into
another building
we might be
unitary with suffolk who knows where
we'll be in five years time
this gives us a good uh stop gap if you
like it gives us time to breathe gives
us time to think and time to
work out how we're going to work best
with our county
officers and i think that's something
that we should also take into account
was one of the benefits of being here
is that we are next to people that we
have contact with and work with in the
county council
i think there are other
benefits that we haven't considered
which is the quality of staff that we
can get here
i mean we're aware of how difficult it
is to get staff let alone good quality
staff and we understand that
it's been pointed out that
staff that are considering joining
working in a hybrid way is one of their
key
requirements one of their key
attractions also working
in ipswich which is
convenient for
essex suffolk etc
hadley was not so convenient i mean i
loved hadley because it was easy for me
to get there from cable
but if you were the other side of
the a12 or the a14 not so easy
you've got modern offices here
hadley was not
a modern office it didn't look like an
office
the services so i think somebody's
mentioned that services
need to be delivered in
here in
endeavour house well we don't do we
don't deliver the services here really
most of the services are delivered out
in the districts
we can organize them
from anywhere
we can work in the communities i like
that idea getting out there into the
communities and i'm sure derek's team
are doing that
melanie most of your concerns were
kind of we've
covered with people having to work at
home they were forced to work with him
they felt
isolated
we're not suggesting that at all all of
the
issues that you brought up could be
dealt with by people working
in a part-time basis here in the office
in a part-time basis at home or a
part-time basis out in the community
you know if if people youngsters feel as
though they need to be in three or four
days a week or five days a week in their
early times and that's they can do that
if they need to be in
to me to have a team meeting they can do
that
there's nothing wrong with this
it also isn't 48 desks
it's that's 48 particular spaces but
there are significantly other
work stations
the other 70 odd
uh workstations aren't there for people
to sit and drink tea and have a chat
they're there for people to work
just a different type of work
so
if we look at the offices that cifco
have
how many of those are we having to
refurbish
in this manner because that makes them
more attractive to
lease out
this is the way this is going to be what
offices of the future will look like
just we're getting in at the ground
floor
nothing wrong with that
we've heard we've got if if we've got
the numbers slightly wrong and we find
that people do want to be in five days a
week on a regular basis
we can find more space in the building
we can adapt the furniture isn't fixed
it can be
adapted
all we're saying here is this is the
first step
the first step
into working in the future not in the
past
let's not get hung up with the way that
things used to be in hadley
five years ten years ago
come on we're better than that
thank you council birthday yeah this is
the 2020s and we need to
uh provide the space that's required now
and moving forward councilman avicii
thank you very much chairman um
it's a bit back to front
usually you conduct a work study to
evaluate the working processes that
determines the amount of time it takes
to carry out any particular functions
that in turn gives you a staffing quota
and an you know
but we haven't had that
or at least we don't seem to have had it
um i think counsellors would be a little
bit
more relaxed if we knew exactly how many
people do work in endeavor house how
many people are based here is it
221 or is that just the number of
correspondents that responded to the
survey
so is that
400 people
what percentage of the total employee
workforce does that represent
um
i also feel that this is a decision it
will impact on all members and therefore
all members should have the right
to hear
and comment on it
that they should be here today to hear
us debating it yes
but we all know
that members don't turn up very few turn
up at any debate or cabinet debate
in fact today we've had more than we've
had for a long long time
in fact probably the last four years
um
by not
letting
the members
have a chew over this
is going to
further reinforce
their sense of disenfranchisement
that it is
environment the environmental impact is
positive
yes
means you're not going to use petrol
diesel
and create
tire particulate on the roads
but research has shown that younger
inexperienced people
prefer working in an office environment
because they lack the skills and the
expertise
that the older members of staff will
have
and i think somebody mentioned that what
sort of facilities have they got at home
that is crucial because if you're
working off the kitchen table that is
not a good working environment
so i think as councillor busby said
this is the first step
um i think it's the first step on this
paper
i think it needs to go back to the
drawing board and
pick up the steer from various members
of the cabinet
and put together something that we can
present to members because it affects
all of us
it's not although it may be an executive
decision as as emily has said it affects
everybody that is connected to
baba
and mid-suffolk council
thank you
sorry can i uh this had
the other members that aren't on cabinet
i agree they should take part in the
discussion if they want to they've had a
chance they've been they could have been
in the work party how does
the staff working in endeavour house
affect them
if they don't come to endeavor house
apart from council meetings
why does it affect them where the staff
are working they can do their job if
just as effectively from home
or out in the community
but we all know that you get we often
get
i'm out of the office and you don't know
when they're coming back
so what's the difference between if
they're coming if they're working in
individuals somebody will be supervising
them to see that they've actually
done an out of office
i think you're living in the 1950s if
you think people are supervising along
those kind of lines
no because it's an issue that needs to
be addressed
okay um councilman vizio
i think we've all taken on board some of
your um
your your comments um
i i
personally don't uh agree i i think that
um
what we're proposing here is is going to
be a lot more flexible and a lot more
accommodating than than i think many of
us here fear um we're not forcing people
to not to come into the office um we're
not
um
making it more difficult for
member
officer interaction at all
what we're doing is is providing
a balanced work environment that's going
to suit people in in the different ways
they work they don't all work
in the same way
five days a week now
and and they need this this flexibility
and quite rightly so it'll improve the
efficiency and
uh and um
the
ability of the
our officers to to do the jobs that um
our residents require um i i think we
are pretty much coming to the end of
this debate councilman mccraw you've got
your hand up so i'll i'll move to you as
the last person before we go to the vote
i've listened to everybody on this and
i've read the papers and thought about
them over and over again and i've worked
in a number of environments more
traditional types
less traditional types and i'm torn i
really am i'm torn right down the middle
um i can see advantages in this i think
it would be that it's an improvements in
the facilities that we would actually
have available i have found it
irritating we didn't have soundproof
rooms at times i think that was that was
a bit of a mistake in all honesty
um
i'm worried i'm concerned obviously the
the use of the spaces 48 68 and 46 but
162 i suppose it's actually a pretty
decent number and and i just wandered
through the building coming up here and
it's just deserted at the moment
i would wonder are we providing support
for officers working from home
particularly in terms of of making sure
that they've got shall i say
comfortable working environments chairs
and all those things
but as far as implementing this and
making the decision that is the job
whether we like it or not we are the
cabinets um it is an executive decision
and i can see the advantage of members
being able to discuss it and consider it
but as it has been pointed out a working
group was involved in the first place so
that's been covered
and it's gone into the report so some
members must be
aware of this
there is a mechanism if
uh members of the council don't like the
decision for them to call it in
and that's what they can do with an
executive decision you might not want to
hear that but that happens to be the
case
so effectively we have to make the
decision and then we have to make the
decision and we have to be ready to
implement by march 2022
this march that is so we haven't got
long
um i think i'm probably going to vote in
favor of this
thank you council mccraw
okay everyone um i think we've had
quite a full and frank debate on on this
item um
and i think it's time now that we moved
to the vote so claire can you conduct
the vote please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in europe
council of girl four thank you
thank you members chair that's six votes
four and four against that's carried
thank you thank you claire
moving on to the final item
this afternoon paper bca2139
haven gateway partnership membership
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
economic development to introduce the
report
council halt
thank you chair
i'd like to introduce this report bca
2139 in which cabinet are asked to
consider whether or not the council
should retain its membership of the
haven gateway partnership be on the 31st
of march 2022.
the economic landscape has changed
significantly since the haven gateway
partnership was established over 20
years ago
new economic partnerships have been set
up such as the new anglia local
enterprise partnership
suffolk growth and more recently
freeport east which have allowed our
businesses to access a range of support
funding and new opportunities to grow
and innovate
the recent announcement announcements
around levelling up could also see
economic partners in the east work more
closely together
whilst i am pleased our council has been
part of the notable success
of all the successes of the haven
gateway partnership
at a time when resources need even more
scrutiny it has been appropriate to
review the future of the partnership
alongside some of the other important
cross-broader priorities and
collaborations
these existing and new partnerships such
as the suffolk climate change
partnership appear to have stronger
links to businesses in our districts
provide new opportunities for routes
into funding and are built upon strong
governance and a united vision for the
future of suffolk and the east
whilst the haven gateway provides a
unique link to north essex
i am confident that the strong
collaboration already developed
with essex as part of the freeport east
will continue to grow and prosper
i therefore propose that cabinet
approved the three recommendations in
this report three point one three point
two and three point three and ask for a
second
thank you council to hold councillor
barrett your second
thank you
questions anyone
okay no questions from the cabinet um
council mclaren do you have any
questions no thank you chair
right um
moving into debate does anyone wish to
uh say anything about this um
from my point of view the the report is
quite clear we've discussed this quite a
bit in the past um
council halt's introduction explains the
rationale behind the recommendations
um
council busby just a quick couple of
questions really one is how much has it
cost us and therefore how much will we
save on an annual basis and have there
been any particular
notable successes
for baber
well seven thousand pounds per annum is
is the cost to the council
and successes um certainly haven gateway
were very
strong in support of the sudbury bypass
proposal
unfortunately it didn't come forward but
they did give us a lot of support
in coming forward with that proposal
thank you council hall
okay then councilman crawl
just draw everybody's attention to 4.13
which sees um virtually everybody else
withdrawing from the partnership and
since those people would be the people
that we would be working mostly in
partnership with and they don't want to
i can't see that we should
uh thank you for that um uh councilman
crawl and i think also and uh i know
informant uh in 4.3 um there's the
comment about possible devolution and of
course as we all know since um this
paper was drafted um
the
county deal for suffolk has has been
confirmed by our government and we're
now going to embark on negotiations
with with government over the
potential for devolving powers to to the
county um that doesn't get in the way of
any further
collaboration and work with our essex
colleagues but but clearly the focus for
suffolk is is going to be on that county
deal
okay um
in which case i think we'll move to the
vote
okay please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
councillor mccrory
in favor
thank you members chair that's 10 votes
for thank you
you